All
[Music]
right, I need everybody to take a deep
breath here because um I'm about to
stress you out and uh but hopefully at
the end I'll uh relieve that stress a
little bit with some ideas and solutions
for you. So, I need everybody to just
think for a second, reflect on the past
45 days and think about all the possible
things that have gone on in our industry
and all the product launches. Let me
highlight just a few for you. Uh, Notion
launched a Granola, Glean, and Chat GPT
competitors. Figma launched a Canva,
framer, illustrator, and lovable
competitor. At Lassian launched a
granola, Glean competitor, plus cloud
integrations. Anthropic launches a Glean
competitor with cloud integrations.
Google launches Codex, Lovable, and many
other competitors. OpenAI bought
a cursor competitor launches codecs and
a lot more. Right? This is just one
little microcosm of the entire tech
industry. But if you look around at all
the different categories of software
right now, the same exact thing is
happening. And I haven't even mentioned
the horde of startups, wellunded
startups, uh that are getting funded in
every single one of these spaces as
well. And among all of this chaos, we
have companies that are essentially
collapsing in months rather than years.
Cheg was one of the first ones to go
that declined to over 90% in the matter
of months. And of course, Stack Overflow
was one of the early victims as well
when chat GPT launched. So this gets to
the number one question that we all need
to be answering, right? A lot of people
at this conference are talking about how
product is doing more engineering,
engineering is doing more product work,
design's doing more product work, all
the tactical, all the technical, all of
those different infrastructure. But none
of that matters. None of it matters
unless you answer this question. What do
I build and why will it win? And the
interesting thing about this is this was
always the job of product. It just
happens to be that over the years it got
marred in all of this uh project
management, agile process, all of this
type of stuff. But this is what always
separated great product managers from
good product managers and product
leaders. This is Sean Claus. He's the
chief product officer at Confluent. He
was formerly chief product officer at
MuleSoft. He was the first head of
growth at Atlassian as well. And I
thought he encapsulated well. He said,
"You're constantly trying to get ahead.
You're trying to find the angle. the
question that has not yet been asked
that gives you an insight that is not
being actioned by other people. It
doesn't just have to be an insight. It
has to be an insight that others are not
actioning because if you find that
insight and others aren't actioning it,
that is your competitive advantage. Now,
the problem is is that this question has
gotten 10x harder. This is a rough map
of uh Gettysburg, and I thought it was a
good analogy because this was one of the
bloodiest battles in the Civil War. And
this kind of represents the map that we
are all playing in in the competitive
environment right now. We have fast huge
moving incumbents like Microsoft, Google
and Meta. There are these new huge
horizontal platforms like chat, GPT and
anthropic that are eating up major use
cases. We have foundational shifts in
the technology landscape not on a yearly
basis on a monthly basis and there are
hordes and hordes of startups being
funded including five or six in every
single capa category that has traction
by YC every single cohort. This is you
sitting in the middle of all of this,
right? And the question is is how in the
world do you find a seam among all of
these players to potentially find some
traction and win? That's the question we
have to answer before any of the other
stuff like technology, infrastructure,
or even what our roles are in the
organization. I'm Brian. I'm founder and
re founder and CEO of Reforge. And uh if
you notice, I have a little bit more
gray hair and wrinkles from this picture
because I've been around in tech for
about 25 years, been doing startups the
whole time. I played in some pretty
competitive environments. I helped
HubSpot launch their CRM almost a decade
ago. And at that time, that was a crazy
competitive category. People thought we
were bonkers. My guess is, if I took a
raise of hand, probably over 50% of your
companies are using that CRM today. Now,
that was a competitive environment. But
what I'm experiencing now and what we're
all experiencing is probably 10x that.
And so, uh, a little history about
Reforge is that we've been around for
about 10 years. We've helped thousands
of product teams, including all the ones
you see here, over 100,000
professionals. I hope some of you have
been part of Reforge in the past. And
the way that we've done it is that we've
built a community of over 400 experts on
the front lines to decode all of their
best practices. We started by doing that
with 40 plus expertled courses,
including our AI courses. But a couple
years ago, we started to take a shift
and started to encode all of this
knowledge into AI agents. Our first one,
Reforge Insights, which acts like your
AI product researcher. Our second one
called Compass is your project manager
that takes care of all of those
low-level, lowv value tasks that involve
product management, automated for you.
We have two more coming later this year.
But back to this question, how do you
win in the intense environment in the
history of technology? I spent a few
months with Ravi Meta thinking about
this exact question. He created our AI
strategy course. He was the former chief
product officer at Tinder. He also was a
product leader at Facebook, Microsoft,
Trip Adviser and a bunch more. And the
way that we start to answer this
question is actually we need to think
about the traps. And the two most common
traps are of course one, how do you like
reinventing the AI wheel? You do not
need to build custom models in
infrastructure in order to answer this
question. And on the opposite side is
the other trap is the other trap which
is just implementing, copying and
pasting basic AI features like chat bots
into your product. The answer actually
lies in the middle which is treating AI
like a series of Lego blocks where you
assemble differentiated AI features and
products by integrating the best
available AI capabilities with your
products data and functionality. Your
competitive advantage will come from
what is uniquely yours. These three
things, your data, your functionality,
and your understanding of unmet customer
needs, not the AI itself. So, let's
think about the anatomy of a winning AI
product. What are the major building
blocks? What are the major Lego pieces?
And how do you stack them together,
connect them to create something
differentiated? Well, we can start to
talk about this, the AI capabilities,
because there's a ton of Lego pieces
that are emerging every year. Whether
it's the pre-trained AI models or the
abilities to perform tasks, audio
processing, imaging process, all of
these new capabilities that feel magical
now that we couldn't do before. But the
thing about all of these Lego blocks is
you just don't have access to them.
Everybody else has access to them as
well. So even though AI products and
features of course use one of these
Legos as its core Lego blocks, this is
not where differentiation and
competitive advantage comes from. That
starts with one of these pieces, your
data. Because your data is what provides
context to a AI model to generate a
unique output. The more unique your data
is, the more unique output you can
generate for customer. And there's a
bunch of different types of data.
There's real- time data that the models
might not have incorporated into their
training set. There's user specific
data. There's domain specific data like
we've seen emerging in le in uh legal in
healthcare. There's human judgment data
around curation as well as reinforcement
data. Now the question about data is how
do you actually combine multiple
categories of data together to form some
uniqueness as well as it's not about the
quantity of your data. It's about the
marginal value of your data over
everybody else especially the big
models. So how much additional value
does your data add over what is already
trained in the models. The third piece
is your functionality because this
determines how the AI behaves and it
gives your AI product superpowers.
There's multiple types of Lego blocks
around your functionality. Specialized
workflows, unique algorithms, business
rules, integrations, whatever it is
that's baked into your product. Now, the
key about assembling all these pieces is
that they work like a system and you
have to connect the system in order to
build that competitive differentiation.
Let's start with this. Your data is what
provides and informs the AI's
understanding. It's what helps you gener
helps the AI generate a unique output.
And that unique output as a result is
what helps you build an additional
repository of unique so that this
continues to to flow in a flywheel. On
the other side of the spectrum is your
functionality. Your functionality in
your product is how your product
controls the AI actions. how it
interacts with AI when it calls it to
create a delightful user experience. And
in addition, AI is AI as uh increasingly
able to call tools in the functionality
of your product itself. And those two
things work together as a system as
well. So let's take all of this theory
and let's put it into practice. Let's
talk about a product granola. Just by a
raise of hands, how many people have
either tried or used granola today?
Okay, pretty decent amount. That's
probably like 40% of the room. A year
ago, that would have been zero. And I
think this is an interesting case
because they entered a space that
already had a horde of other AI
notetakers, whether that was Fathom,
Otter, Fireflies, there was a ton of
them. Um, but somehow they found a scene
and they've ga garnered 40% of your
attention in this room and about 50
million in funding. So, let's go back to
those three fundamental questions in
those Lego bricks. what was uniquely
theirs, their data, their functionality,
and their understanding of their unmet
customer need. I'm going to start with
the last one. So, at the time when they
entered the market space, this is this
is just a sample of people who are
already in market including all of the
incumbents like Zoom and Meet that have
AI native note-taking capabilities, but
they were all approaching it from the
perspective of the product is going to
do something for the user. It's going to
replace the full job. They want somebody
else to take my meeting notes. What they
realize is actually there's a whole
other set of customer needs that have
been unmet, which is I don't want you to
take all of my notes. I just want you to
help me take better notes. Empower me
around this specific task and user. And
that's what they built the product
around. Now, in order to start, they
used off-the-shelf capabilities. No
unique models, no custom training,
nothing. They used deep gram for
transcription. They used anthropic and
open AI for some of their other
functionality, but the uniqueness came
in how they assembled the Lego blocks.
Starting with on the lefth hand side
with granola's data, right? Their
context includes both the notes that you
take as well as the transcription that
they generate. They use the AI Lego
block to generate a unique output, which
is they enhance better notes. Those
notes over time form a repository that
starts to enable all sorts of other
features that they've layered on like
chatting across meetings, uh their
project workspaces, all their downflow
actions. So they have this nice flywheel
of unique context in data that's
starting to spin that was partially
enabled by the right hand side of the
Lego blocks, their functionality. They
used a Mac app so that they could detect
when meetings started to access the
system sound for transcription by being
right there at the user h uh the the
user moment that they needed it to
enable the AI to do those things. And
they've also plugged into other tools
and integrations like the calendar to
get metadata about the meetings such as
attendees. So they assembled these Lego
blocks to meet in that unique way to
meet that unique customer need. Now the
question is, is granola going to
survive? I've got no idea, right? It's
an incredibly competitive landscape
because the real the realization is that
you can't stop here. You can't stop by
just assembling your initial set of Lego
bricks. You have to sequence over and
over again. You have to take those first
three Lego LEGO bricks, leverage them
into another unique set that you
assemble. And you see Granola doing
this. Now that they've enabled this,
they've started to create project and
team workspaces and start to uh enable a
new set of unique use cases off of the
initial layer that um they did. They've
started to integrate downstream actions
like uh connecting to your CRM and
HubSpot. Uh that I just saw them the
other day experimenting with a company
wiki that autoupdates itself. So they
continue to sequence these things into a
unique set of building blocks. The
question is is will they keep up? I
don't know. Jamon Ball, a partner at
Alterimator Capital, recently wrote a
newsletter and he said, "The real moat
is just a sequence of smaller moes
stacked together. Each one buys time.
What you do uh with that time, how fast
you execute, how quickly you evolve
determines whether you stay ahead. If
the moat used to be 6 to 12 months,
today it's 2 to 3 weeks.
So to recap, to win an AI besides being
stressed out, right, is to answer what
are your unmet customer problems?"
That's always been a part of product,
right? The second is what AI
capabilities can solve those problems in
novel ways. What proprietary data can
power those solutions? And then what
superpowers can our product give to AI?
How do you assemble those three
foundational Lego blocks? All right.
Thank you. If you're if you're an AI
engineer, we are hiring. Our team will
be outside. We can play with products
with instant distribution to 300,000
people. And if you need help with
anything else, just check out
reforge.com.
Good luck.
[Music]